foreign
we have another question here this one
is from Crystal
hey this is Crystal from Malaysia well I
used to allow the outcomes of my actions
to Define who I was but I've come to
realize we are not our failures nor our
successes so who do you think we are
then when we let go of our attachments
our first or our second book Ryan
started with this line our our our
identities are shaped by the costumes we
wear and I meant costumes literally like
Ryan and I used to wear a suit every day
to go into work and that became part of
my identity but also our costumes can be
the oversized house the luxury car
nothing wrong with these things morally
but also understanding our identities
get wrapped up in a lot of these things
that we didn't even know we wanted but
because we're following someone else's
path we're accumulating the same things
that they accumulated we thought those
things were going to make us happy
and then enter Julianne Smith with a
line like this would your childhood self
be proud of you or embarrassed
and that's a difficult question to sit
back and
and ask where did that question come
from
it I when I hear that first of all
I'm shocked that I wrote it uh-huh
because again it would be impossible to
confront someone directly with that
question and the only reason I was able
to write it is because I'm writing it to
myself and writing it to an unknown
public but the great thing about being
presented with that is that you can then
look at that question and you can ask
ask it yourself of yourself and be able
to say hold on a second what what did I
intend to do
what what what did I think was
impressive or just magical or
what did I think was special
when I was a kind of a pure less scarred
up version of myself and
and
can I can I be honest and can I be
authentic to that person
now in some way in some small tiny way
like what kind of thing can I do that is
is it an authentic reflection of who I
am instead of uh trying to represent me
to a certain
uh set of people that I'm trying to
impress out in the outside world like I
need it's I am the person I need to
impress I'm the person that I need to be
proud of not other people
if that comes secondarily great if it
doesn't
who cares if I love myself and if I am
able to be proud of myself
would you say that is is the essence of
who we are that that capacity for
self-love that capacity for creativity
and reinvention I think that there is an
authentic person first of all versus
like a blank slate right and you where
you can reinvent everything and and turn
it to zero so so to me I I feel that a
person can reconnect and it's not like
some Freudian thing where they need to
connect with their inner child or but
but they can connect with a version of
themself that that
feels
special and that feels uh that they have
a bright future and that feels that when
they do ABC thing that those things are
special and amazing and just just like I
I have a
I have a to-do that reoccurs in my
system of to do is that I manage right
yeah and uh sometimes they're just
thoughts that I want to remember and
this one uh that occurs to me on a
regular basis when I see it is have you
experienced the sacred recently that's
all that the question asks and I'm like
yes or no and then I check it off and
then it'll recur like 45 days or
something in the future right and and so
a super vague question
but
it's really meaningful for me
and when I look at it I know what the
answer is yes or no and sacred is not
sacred universally it means something
different to someone else than it does
to me but it lets me say
okay like was there something special
that I experienced that I felt was was
worthwhile and I know when I've
experienced those moments and I bet
anyone else knows too right and that
gives them a sense as to whether they
have done something
that maybe would their child itself
would be proud of or embarrassed have
you written this checklist anywhere
because I want to know more about this
checklist yeah that's a very powerful
checklist it really is man that's uh wow
that's incredible man
um yeah yeah I won't push you on it
um maybe you can just text it to me I
won't share it I promise
don't believe him he has automatic
tweets shut up anything you text him
just goes out automatically that's right
this is the worst app idea ever no okay
so getting back to the Crystal's
question here though um it makes me
think about when we were in Nashville
Andy Davis opened up for us and we did
you know we did our talk and we were
doing the Q a and someone asks Josh like
well you've given up all your your
things so I just have a simple question
for you who are you and Josh had the
best answer because I'm like oh I'm glad
she didn't ask me that because I don't
know how I would answer that right
um but Josh hi Josh said uh I am what I
desire and I was like that was actually
really profound I know you were just
giving her something back that was kind
of ethereal sounding but that has really
stuck with me obviously because you know
nine years later I'm talking about it
wow but but it is true it's like when I
think about who we are as a person or
who I am as a person well first off the
older I get the less I identify with
this Ryan nicodemuses and then like
having a mission statement it's more
about it is what I desire coupled with
um what am I trying to give you know to
to the world or Community or my friends
or family or whatever it is and couple
that with the purpose that I serve which
uh I've talked about this a little bit
but you know we always talk about
where's my purpose uh you know Julian
has a purpose Josh has a purpose where's
my purpose but purpose is not it's
I don't see it as an ownership thing
purpose is something that when you serve
it properly it'll own you yeah and like
what sorry this is a very very crazy way
to say it and so
just take this with a grain of salt
perhaps uh patrons uh but it's like it's
like what are you willing to die for
because that's kind of what you're doing
regardless
so you might as well be willing to spend
that time in that way and
um and if not and I I want to emphasize
again please take the language that I'm
using it's deliberately provoking
take it in that way it's like
this time is passing what is worth it
what is really worth it to you did you
enjoy this Standalone patreon highlight
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalists private podcast
available exclusively on patreon visit
patreon.com the minimalists or click the
link in the description your support
keeps our podcast and YouTube Channel
100 advertisement free